all right Todd is with us in California
hey Todd welcome to Dave Ramsey show hey
Dave thank you for taking my call got
kind of a conundrum here this up I just
discovered you within the last month or
so and trying to get things going
good I work I work for a governor entity
in the state of California and there's a
good chance I could be having a
medically retired between now and
sometime in the next five years and I'm
only forty years old I'm trying to get
everything situated for me and my wife
and our three kids she's actually
listening to group taking notes I'm
about to receive a settlement check for
workers comp and I want to use that the
payoff are roughly eighteen thousand
dollars in debt that we have outside of
our vehicle payment and we have forty
two thousand on the vehicle I have
roughly $30,000 in a 457 plan as well as
the retirement through the State
Retirement System and I also get a VA
disability pension as well so what's
your household income in a year uh right
now it's ninety three employment with
another 40 from give or take 40 from the
VA mighty expensive car it's uh you yeah
had to pack three kids into it so you
can re kids into a fifteen thousand
dollar car that I get that and that's
why I'd never bought myself a new truck
yeah with that I didn't after the 26 K
time I get initially from the set amount
and I get about eleven hundred a month
after that for about twenty four months
are you out of work on vision no no I'm
still employed but I'll probably be
getting forced to medically retire
between sometime between now and in the
next five years why because of my you
know injuries I've sustained from work
okay
sorry but you're only foolish you're
only 45 years old 40 40 40 so what are
you going to do for the rest of your
life I have no clue one thing I do know
is if it does come we need to oh it's
coming I know it's coming in
that's why I can't eat helping guidance
or someone to take me in the rear to
kind of force me into a direction teeth
get this going for my family five years
from now your children are going to be
hungry yes you need to get it you need
to have a career path starting right now
ready set go
yeah like I'd be really really really
concentrating on this because the
medical retirement might come in 36
months instead of 60 gotcha and you will
be screwed brother and we well we also
live in state provided government
housing so I pay 450 a month in rent
yeah and I know that when it does come
we do want to leave the state of
California so one we're not paying okay
sure godly living well and and maybe you
short-circuit and and unless there's
some kind of a benefit for waiting it
out financially but let's figure out
what we want to be in our next chapter
act - the curtain goes down the curtains
go up and what are we going to do after
we take that first bow this is your
encore career and the good news is
you're a lot smarter than when you pick
the last career so I'm gonna spend some
time on the back porch with a cup of
coffee and with the love of your life
thinking about what I'm good at
what makes me smile when I'm doing it
and how can I make a big pile of money
doing that okay and what do I need to go
take a class or six do I need to get a
certification do it what do I need to do
where are we gonna do this am i starting
a business am I gonna become a violinist
I don't know what you're going to do I
don't care but you need to really be
focusing on that because it's not a
matter of if now it's just a matter of
when
am I wrong yeah no you're right and when
it does happen between the disability
retirement and the VA it'll be between
six and seven grand a month coming in
yeah so it'd be a very opportune time to
already have done this preparation work
to make the transition and not go from
income to only disability income I mean
what if you had that six or seven grand
coming in and
you had a job lined up in the new career
or you had your business idea ready and
you're ready to move to another state in
the whole deal right guy so let's think
about it that way meantime I'm gonna go
ahead and move down in car because I
want you to be free it listen if you're
sitting there with no debt and a pile of
money while we're making all these
decisions
it changes the decisions gotcha and
right now this car is out of line it's
not all the way into the crazy zone but
it's getting close and so yeah I want
you in a fifteen thousand dollar kid
hauler right now not a forty mm let's
get them all paid off you can pay off
everything but 26 with this one you pay
off first twenty six with this check and
then let's develop a good long-term game
plan hold on I'm gonna send you a copy
of Ken Coleman's book the proximity
principle which will help you get into
the career you love